I'm taking this month off and while I'm
gone five other YouTube creators have
lined up some brilliant guest videos for
you
we start with science presenter Steve
mold and when Tom at the title of this
video I thought no I can't and then I
was wrong so be nice
be kind speed take away you have a
superpower that you're probably not
aware of the ability to hear temperature
at least the ability to discern between
hot and cold water just using your sense
of hearing and this is something we can
test so I'm going to pour hot and cold
water from these identical jugs into
these identical mugs and it's your job
to figure out which is which and I'm
going to blow the screen as well because
there may be some visual cues that would
tip you off one way or the other okay
here we go
it should have been quite easy to tell
which was which feel free to pause the
video and leave a comment with your
guess if you like but here's the answer
the first port was cold and the second
port was hot and the reason they sound
different is because the fact that water
is viscous or thick if you like and the
viscosity of water goes down when you
heat it this is something that's easier
to see with a liquid like honey so warm
honey is more runny than cold honey
whereas with water it's less visually
apparent but when you pour water the way
it splashes into a cup is affected by
the viscosity and this change in the
splashing of the water changes the sound
that it makes because of various complex
fluid dynamic reasons
what's really interesting is this is
knowledge you already had due to a
lifetime of hearing cold drinks and hot
drinks being made and like many things
this is something that you knew
intuitively even though it wasn't
something you are aware of consciously
go subscribe to speed mold Channel i
would recommend his video on a self
pouring liquid as being a good place to
start
next time the tale of an engineering
disaster
you